our next guest has truly set the gold
standard she is an incredible
innovative art teacher from arizona and
she re-engaged her students in the
pandemic
by bringing the outside world of art and
nature
straight to her students screens in the
last year she's taken her 400 students
on over 40 virtual field trips now
this is a person i want to have this
discussion with you please welcome the
amazing teacher candace green
hi candidate thank you for having me i'm
so excited
well can i ask what gave you the idea to
do this because i was reading that
you know kind of like 40 of your
students at one point were attending
they probably felt disengaged you know
the pandemic was starting
everybody was freaking out
what gave you the idea to do this
because now you have complete engagement
with your students
yes so you know in the first quarter of
the school year
it was really difficult um i have
over 400 students and only about 40 of
my students were showing up on a regular
basis to our
in uh to the virtual classroom and the
ones that did show up
they were not turning their cameras on
they wouldn't
unmute and talk they wouldn't even type
in the chat so i would just be talking
to myself for 45 minutes and then
they weren't turning in assignments and
um in the regular classroom every year
my favorite thing to do is to go on
field trips i love field trips i love
exposing my kids to the arts around them
and i write many grants every year and i
just thought wow
what about this opportunity that i have
that
it's easier to do field trips this way
and still expose my students
and hopefully will engage them and make
them want to come into the virtual
classroom so
i started these live virtual field trips
i love that
i mean just think about that's the
innovation we're talking about where you
know we could have been so
limited with what's what we've been
through but you've taken this technology
and and really just
changed the game you've taken over 40
trips traveled hundreds of miles i know
you get results the kids are
totally engaged right oh absolutely
um my numbers now i went from 40
of students to showing up to 99 of my
students
amazing right
that's phenomenal um you put together
art kits
to engage your students in like a more
hands-on kind of way can you tell us
about those
sure i knew that um while we were at
home
these students wouldn't have access to
art supplies like they would have if
we were in the classroom so i wanted to
be able to give
each of my students supplies so i
started uh like asking for donations
on facebook and gathering supplies and i
wanted to give
each kid a kit so
right now i'm at 380 kits and my goal is
400
so all my students will be able to get
art supplies so i've got 20 more to go
well your generosity of time spirit and
energy has certainly made a huge
difference in the lives of these
students and our friends
at uli want to help you finish those
kits so they're going to send you
9 000 dollars
oh thank you and it's 9
000 you inspired this company to do that
that's amazing thank you so much oh my
gosh i
am so grateful for what you do
because i do think that
getting people interested in the arts is
not
sort of the easiest thing to do
sometimes
and the fact that you decided to
see 40 percent interest in online
virtual learning
i'm a parent i saw my kids too they
they couldn't get engaged they were
struggling
and i was struggling as a parent and so
for you
to see this discrepancy and try to make
it
interesting to try and rope them back in
and harness them and and get them
reignited
that's what you did candace it's amazing
it is thank you thank you thank you
thank you for what you do and thank you
to uli
hey
uh amazing i just think about in a time
when we we
were literally locked down you just
showed your kids the world
and i think that is amazing what you did
candace
thank you that was perfectly put well
she did it
thank you thank you candace and i really
hope that what you did
continues to inspire other people may we
keep expanding each other's horizons
when you think you're limited ross is
right
you showed the possibilities thank you
thank you candace green
you